[Music]
everybody's happy why because I know the
new leader has better things in store
for them an absolute guarantee that
you're any
like to deserve for my leg find out what
mr. mrs. John Q public think about it
lovely little lady coming my way right
now you'd wonder what she had to say
come on miss ball what did they think
until year's eve
[Applause]
I go you do trust me nothing to be after
two weeks engagement amazing faces fired
an actress of vulnerability working a
department store well that's show
business for you one thing if I'm ever
called upon to play the part of his
package wrapper I'll be confirmed
couldn't do it better what you need is a
couple of rooms somewhere and a husband
to look after you I might consider
Charlie McCarthy he'll you wouldn't have
you really knew him
you know thing I've been thinking lately
that prep Charlie and I oughta separate
separate you and Charlie I know what
people just aren't interested in
ventriloquist and they're dummies oh hey
you are in a bad way
come on snap out of it it's a new year
and it's going to be a quickie good for
both of us I know
like that
I don't know what my speed
[Applause]
[Music]
Holly's up here hey you'll come back
here come on darling come on we've got
to get out of here what's the matter I
thought the landlady gave us till Monday
to dig up there in smoke this how do you
know the buildings on fire
Wow let's get out of here the juggling
Jacobus does get out all right hey
juggling Djokovic shook it all right all
right all right take it easy
all right come on pull pull back get
back I don't like a guy like this you
ask him a civil question and he say I
know you well that makes me happy oh no
honestly I do you live right up there in
that third floor front I live across the
street you see what the people are up
there in the window my house is burning
and he's asking me riddle
[Music]
oh did you get my letter what letter she
wrote she to tell you the house was on
fire okay okay don't go wait wait hey
come back
where are you going are you nuts
this place is on fire come back here of
all the stupid date of all the dumb
Dora's risking our lives don't ask you
to follow me that stuff maybe that thing
is locked well if you stop shouting at
me for a minute I might be able to open
it come on come on will you please get
what you're after let's get out of here
that must be very important document
don't be afraid come on let's go this
way
don't worry look be out of here Nativity
[Music]
that's got it whoa whoa wait a minute
wait a minute I'm all right how are we
going to get down let's go this way
come on Vinnie jump jump oh yes I think
so
[Music]
hey are you all right yeah thanks
I'd have been down there yet if it
weren't for you you saved my life
Hana you're not gonna try to make a hero
[Applause]
that's where I live
so you told me all later you haven't
heard anything yet do you know I have a
confession to make to you I've been
sitting in that window for months
looking right into your life Oh what
peeping tom yeah isn't it awful I could
tell when you were high and I could also
tell when you were blue and many's the
time you made my mouth water when you
were poaching eggs over that electric
iron
let's go
don't get em push like a baby will get
back my name is McCarthy I don't care
what your name is get back
[Music]
I got it I rather he did thank goodness
you're safe
officer will we be able to go in there
no one can go in there the places are
right see that's kind of tough burn out
on New Year's Eve there now they're
thrown out what's the difference well uh
what do you fellas gonna do all will
curl up with a nice book somewhere hey
I've got an idea why don't you come up
to my place we're having a little party
I think I don't care for you uh-huh
Green finds the help hope you don't mind
you're lucky they're out there's no
fresh out looks like just another fire
cabin you asked me I didn't ask the fire
is out ladies and gentlemen I've brought
you back a couple of refugees miss Kay
Martin mr. Edgar Bergen meet the butcher
lights of Broadway take your coat who
are the bush life
I'll ask they're artists who hide their
lights under bushes the place certainly
looks lived in quiet you see the
juggling took over sir did they get out
all night I hope so I didn't see them
my name is honey honey hope you didn't
lose anything I don't think so we'll
know in the morning be it thank you yeah
thank you
Birgit quiet can't you see I'm trying to
drink yes but honey honey didn't give
Charlie Charlie anything I beg your
pardon
honey's my partner she's a swell kid
you'll like it what do you do we dance
just at the moment according to our
agents were resting after a long and
arduous tour and what do you do well I'm
officially - I'm resting after a long
run in Schubert's outer office the whole
congratulations you are Charlie dear
Oh last but not least I thank you ai ai
ai ai ai
too much beer isn't good for little boy
till lunch there no uh-huh
why are you certainly to care that
that's fine yeah yeah oh yeah I will
it's good yeah well I wouldn't know
about that no a ventriloquist can you
beat that I didn't think they existed
anymore when a house burns you never
know what's coming out I don't think I'm
gonna like her
Okara
this is Miss Kmart how he did huh and
that's Edgar Bergen how did how did you
how do you do this is Cara Phelps she's
working do tell
well you need to look jealous it's only
a walk-on I appear in the third act and
say I'm Geoffrey's wife he's killed
himself
can you blame him for injury shame the
great big dummy like you making fun of
my acting he's my favorite I didn't know
you were acting
I really ought to be thinking of a place
to sleep I'll leave that to honey she'll
figure it out she in the land right here
just like that
he is nice ladies and gentlemen we speak
to you from the Rainbow Room at
Rockefeller Center
it is now 15 seconds before midnight
[Music]
oh my
my will
[Music]
anyway okay thank you and your many of
them me too yes Johnny you too
and nasty your hair is gone wrong I hope
the new ones much more fun I hope so
Happy New Year Happy New Year or excuse
me
[Applause]
very happy new year looks like a good
game we ought to get into Bergen Happy
New Year very and a Happy New Year to UK
[Music]
shall we dance
[Music]
what is this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I would know what to call that would you
love I look down it's beginning to snow
you'd better come inside where it's warm
and close the window oh wait a minute
little fresh air is good for it not me
good night dear Ali and I got out in the
cops for you thanks I'll be right down
night dad good night honey good night I
feel terribly guilty letting honey do
all this for me
oh don't worry about her she likes it
honey's got the biggest heart in the
world that must be the dawn see what's
getting right over there in the top of
that building the dawn of the new year
does it mean that much to it everything
you said you were gonna tell me what was
in that letter did I sure don't you
remember you said it was a passport to
fame and fortune and happiness it might
easily be are you thinking of getting
married no nothing like that
well then I can't imagine what it could
be it's a letter of introduction to John
mannery John Mannering
the great lover well so they say on the
screen and then private life too he's
also a very great actor oh he's a great
actor all right all the Mannings are
good actors well I hope it brings you
good luck Thanks it's getting cold I
think I'd better go I guess that ought
to be comfortable Thanks have you
enjoyed them together along the five
years the five long hide Jesus but I
don't regret today if it buries thinks
well he's taught me and I've helped him
and all we needed to break to get right
up on top with Rogers and Astaire and we
get there
nothing can stop us of course not
throw a slipper ready I'll be all right
good night good night
John memory celebrated stage and screen
star and Vidya white is pretty 22 year
old bride-to-be were greeted by a throng
of eager well-wishing fans as they
stepped off the gangplank yesterday
afternoon
miss Hoyt will be the first mrs.
Mannering the fourth mrs. Mannering
they're not divorce him I had to be like
that
how about it they think we're harder why
Sir to listen to the young turkey what
time is it Barry uh it's two o'clock
hurt hey you better wear that hey I
guess I'll have to my only nice one was
talk to the fire okay yes don't you
think you'd better phone mannery first
and ask for an appointment
mm-hmm I've been carrying his letter
around for a month I'm not going to give
him a chance to put me off I'm not
you're putting too much faith in that
letter mm-hmm well if he doesn't do
anything for you I hope you won't be too
disappointed but he will bury this is
the beginning of everything for me man
I've never and can do a lot right on
Broadway here try this huh
oh honey oh you're an angel
hey they got disabled tables
I wouldn't dare oh they came out of a
hock shop on 6,000 ER sales get that no
well one thing Cole rabbits next you can
have 1/3 interest for $4 oh they're
lovely how do I look you look swell
I don't know husband thank you have you
got your letter yes well I'll come back
as soon as I've seen if it's good news
the praise on me goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye good luck I wonder if she'll see
him I wonder if he'll see her wonder
what'll happen if this to each other
might be there if they didn't see each
other might be better if you shut up
yeah let us another way of looking at
yes I'd like to see mr. Manning please
mr. Manning is occupied he's seen no one
well I'm sure he'll see me I have a
letter of introduction from whom well if
you let them come inside I'll tell you
[Applause]
we say you had a letter yes did you give
it to me I'll see that it reaches mr.
Mallory in due course then perhaps an
appointment to be arranged
well I couldn't do that I'll have to see
him personally actually out of the
question
this gentleman has been waiting since a
half after 1:00 you see how it is I have
a great deal of patience but it won't
lunch or like that my dear dude warning
you this happens to be a superb example
of a baccarat prayer but it is not
intended to be used as an ashtray Oh
June it was a cloudy day the cemetery of
parishes was the sleet gray of a Joseph
and L skyscape I walked down the path
past the tomb of Eloise and Abelard and
I stopped in reverence before it if all
the memory of their now that no man
could put asunder
I beg your pardon sir no man could put
asunder I went on in the midst until I
came to where your sated grandmother lay
and there one by one add you directly I
let drop the spring disappear drop was
kind of you to remember miss you for a
friend it was nothing you stupid fool
you imbecile I told you not to darken it
too much I wanted a bit of gray cut over
the temple and you made it provided to
pay the Confessor such a gray would look
at infinitely more studied stop lying
only with one there are a number of
important Madison and the old jewel this
letter from blue would stop why would he
say you old horse things just a
salutation of the letter sir you see you
old horse thief I sent you a play three
months ago you needn't read it just say
you'll do it and get back in the theater
where you belong affectionately loo take
a letter Andrews my dear old friend
nothing other it could ever induce me to
return to the theatre
rat listen yes sir I should keep the
manuscript as a souvenir
affectionately John anything else yes
sir there's a lady with a letter of
introduction sir well tell her to leave
it I'm much too busy with pleasure sir
in a newspaper reporter a journalist
well now we mustn't be ungracious to the
press has he a photographer with him no
sir but he may have a candid camera they
hide them in the most extraordinary
places sir
I'll get in five minutes no more very
good sir my coat and rose yes
[Applause]
I do miss oldrover what's this one's
name Blitzen sir he's German Richard did
you buy oh no - he's very tame I'm sure
he won't bite sir well I'm not citizen
Blitzen sit why do you talk to him -
foreign language he doesn't understand
English sir but he's beautifully
mannered sit lie down written by a very
lovely picture sir you may come in now
not you him
good afternoon my friend I'm afraid that
I can make no sleep without my
forthcoming plans until after the
wedding
well that's too bad but you are John
Mannering aren't you sir what's this
just a summons mr. Mannering for
non-payment of alimony sorry to trouble
you reporter
how you doing mr. Mallory hey I have a
letter of introduction
oh yes the letter of introduction uh I
hope I didn't frighten you oh that's
quite all right it's safe to come in now
sir watch you come inside thank you sit
down thank you
handwriting is familiar consoles very
easy I don't believe you can guess I
think you have to read it
[Applause]
[Applause]
can you say something where have you
been my dear why haven't I known I
didn't know myself until recently take
off yeah no no touch
let me see you just as you are yes I see
it now same forehead same lovely hair
only your mother's I imagine is turning
gray it turned very fast toward the end
he's dead a few months ago I was in New
York trying to get a job someone wired
me when I got there she she gave me the
letter it was the first time I knew she
thought she owed it to me and perhaps to
you and made me promised it forgive me
forgive you
oh my dear I don't want to be any bother
it bother my dear girl let me look at
you again that takes me back there were
tears in her eyes to the last time I saw
her
[Applause]
after all these years two things that I
found joy the first thing I remember was
mother cutting out your clippings and
placing them in a big yellow scrapbook
later I used to read the notices and
pretend they were mine let's see I I
played Ophelia with you and Rosalind
Roxanne who I was wonderful in that and
of course we went to all your pictures
I don't think mother ever missed any
sometimes halfway through the story I'd
see tears in her eyes I asked her why
she said the scene was sad once I teased
her about it said she was too old to
have a crush on a movie star she didn't
answer but I thought I'd hurt her so I
never mentioned it again how'd everyone
really knows why do you say that if I
had already realized that how could I
I was so young at the time excitable
ambitious without experience and the
famous name to live up to when she
refused to leave Nashville and take to
the road with me I I thought you didn't
care
we quarreled I meant to go back but
somehow the time never came there was
always a new season and you play oh I'm
so sorry
maybe yeah I had no idea please don't
let me disturb you
many of darling what a surprise is that
new yes sir come did I let you make my
day mr. Kamath miss Martin how do you do
miss Mott how do you do I'm afraid I've
stayed too long will you excuse me thank
you for being so kind and I won't bother
you again until I hear from you
will you excuse me I left I'll see you
to the elevator
goodbye goodbye
[Applause]
I haven't even your address how stupid
of me I'll write it down
I feel the worst kind of blackout why I
started to tell her I had a big
intention of telling her but the word
daughter seemed to stick in my throat I
guess being your father so suddenly has
upset me
I understand you can't suddenly spring a
daughter on an unsuspecting world oh I
guess I'm just a vain and pompous idiot
no you're not you're famous near a
reputation and please believe me I don't
want to complicate your life if anything
I'd like to add a little happiness to it
I'd like to feel that you can count on
me for anything as a father should the
first time in my life I I can't find
words let's not bother about telling it
now it's been our secret for so long
let's keep it that way will you kiss me
I'm proud of you goodbye and I'll call
you soon goodbye
[Applause]
barber protege why do you lie to me do
you think I'm a stupid little fool now
calm yourself Liddy I didn't lie you
know I didn't you said she was about but
she was about I mean there was a bomb
now she's a protege whose name you
couldn't even remember lies lies lies
honey she came to me with a letter of
introduction from a very dear friend oh
all right if you don't believe me here
it is no no I'm not going to show it to
you this is no way to begin a marriage
you ought to know you've had enough
experience this trust heal is not with
you quote anything out screams Greene go
ahead good for you I warn you John I'm
not going to be long suffering like some
of your other wives the first time I
catch you double-crossing me I'll walk
out on you so fascinating my adored one
how can you be so unfair to yourself
don't you be unfair that's all I ask
so lovely so charming well I would know
more go on I can feel the cameras
grinding what you feel is the beat of my
heart howling for love of you I must be
out of my mind to think of marrying you
just plain mad yes hey dude some money
they put those steps and then should be
halfway to Benton Harbor Michigan uh-huh
hey when do we danced all I wonder where
she could be it's after six o'clock I
don't know but I wish she'd hurry I'm
dying to find out what happened
why don't you think you're gonna shut up
Johnny oh now lady a minute now now
let's reconstruct this from a scientific
point of view attractive girl goes to
great lovers apartment to ask a favor
see how let me see if I was a great
lover and a girl came to my apartment
oh boy thanks your answer very very good
Oh
okay Oh Barry I'm so happy I'm going
kept you so late oh if I could only tell
you tell me what kind of sweetest earth
man I've ever known
no wonder all the women are crazy about
it yeah that's just what I was afraid
oh really if you could just see them are
hearing talk wait a minute wait a minute
you haven't forgotten me have you ferry
remember Barry page the fellow that's
crazy about you oh I love you I love you
I love you I love everybody just a
second are you by any chance making love
to me I'm thinking about him oh don't be
ridiculous that guy must be a wizard
yeah well the dinners on me did you get
in
honestly I don't know where to begin
he's wonderful I can tell you that much
did he show you is that you oh people
are all wrong talk about him the way
they do he's a darling he wouldn't harm
a flea well it's nice to know he draws
the line somewhere Oh Charlie keep quiet
tell me Kay what's he going to do for
you anything
well we didn't have time to talk about
it but I'm sure he well we didn't have
time you've been gone for hours
well I was late in getting there and
then I had to wait to see him and we had
tea in the door I'm famished let's hear
the rest about him at dinner all right
where should we go Johnny go too of
course if you take that dummy will upset
the whole restaurant again and I'll
hiding me under a shawl either I go as
an American citizen or I'll stay at home
in the trunk I don't blame you Charlie
come in hello homers Martin for me who
is it he says it's John Mannering can I
have my doubts
excuse me please hello tonight he hasn't
lost much time and headache she must
have made him hit yeah oh of course I'll
come where and when the Park Plaza meet
be there at 8:00 all right look feel
prettiest all right I'll be there at
8:00 goodbye Barry yeah he wants me to
have dinner with him do you mind me mine
no certainly not go right ahead oh don't
be that way well how would you expect me
to be happy because you're broken a date
with me to go up with another guy
especially after boom
all afternoon it look like that or if
you only knew oh please be sensible
Mannering isn't another guy as you put
it he's a man who's going to be married
in a week he's in love with Lydia heart
she has a headache and he's free for
this evening there won't be another
chance and he's kind enough to give this
evening to me and my worries it means a
great deal to me Barry you know that
doesn't that make any sense at all to
you
well sure it makes sense I haven't got
to come back I can't find a flaw in your
argument anywhere it's logical it's
convincing it's reasonable in its sound
but just the same and nevertheless I'm
sore as a poison pop that's masculine
logic for you the logic are no logic if
that guy Mannering makes up happy even
in his memory even in madam your table
is ready
[Music]
[Music]
react to chest before Vanessa rate from
Palm Beach by playing this morning I'm
going to leave it to you in time but
remember this is a very special occasion
thank you
[Music]
what are you smiling at
not add anything just about everything
would be perfectly frank I'm not all
together sorry the Lydia had a headache
this evening
what would Lydia do you heard that mm-my
started to think but don't misunderstand
me I know it's just that it's so nice to
have this evening all along you pay it's
John Manley I'm Lydia
that's lady you're wearing that isn't
Lydia stop squinting and eat your dinner
now tell me all about yourself where you
live how you live your friends are
booked you are I'm not broke the money's
holding out carefully budgeted the only
trouble is the money and the budget
don't seem to come out together at the
end of the month you know Mannering ever
made a budget let alone live up to it
you won't have to worry about that
anymore my dear
strain your neck if you're not careful I
don't care I think it's terrible three
weeks until the wedding and he's out
with another girl you wouldn't be
calling Lydia would you don't be upset
the nearest telephone is right out there
[Music]
[Music]
hello video darling this is Maude
my dear Maude rally oh don't you well
John and I are both worn out we've been
going so hard I'll be glad when the
wedding's over any well then everything
is all right I'm so relieved when I told
John come in with someone else and
someone why where are you calling from
the Park Plaza but I did want to find
out if everything was all right of
course John was a sensation when he
walked in as you Sara Sara I'm going on
yes we've been very lucky we've skipped
all the bad part you've never had to
lecture me because I flunked algebra
you've never had to decide about schools
and report cards and taffeta party
dresses whether I should Bob my hair for
the joke but with a proper boyfriend for
me
why is he Catherine he was the butcher's
son Oh most unsuitable I haven't seen
him since I was 13
and there hasn't been anyone since Oh
one or two one or two well one one at a
time is enough I found it that way with
my lives you're very frank about them
well I never take my wives to person I
don't allow myself to become too deeply
attached because I hate to suffer you
see I know so well in advance that the
time is coming when they can't stand it
any longer
they'll have to divorce me it's
self-protection didn't it ever strike
you to be so nice and faithful that they
wouldn't want abortion I always think I
have then something happens but Lydia
it's going to be different
you
evening mother good evening madam
looking for someone
well yes sir never mind I found I'll be
dance I don't know
Catherine will you excuse me alone idea
if you figure that I'm in a slight
predicament what I'm caught
[Music]
wait a minute I don't new for the last
time you're not gonna make a fool out of
me this is why you're being foolish I
told you this I wouldn't go into a
two-timing me that was the talking
you're making a scene so the Taurus
meets the matter may I have your
autograph oh I'm sorry I'm tight
give me a cab wait what are you
apologizing night all right
you
[Music]
I better not wait any longer
something must have happened very good
madam oh but I was with mr. Mallory
would the Maitre d'Hotel he is gone for
the night for them I am on your with her
I couldn't read the responses 321 down
the chicken fillets it has Jeremy sook
leche is not exactly chicken madam
could I know your phone I certainly
letter this week
Larry that's where the let's come
alright so I forgot that what's the
matter with you tonight
oh it's 11 o'clock generally gets to be
around this time when we finally get a
chance for a job but it was only a
chance let's drop the whole thing for
the night huh
you know she ought to be home right now
oh that's it huh
they're worried about cam a big bad wolf
you act as though she were made of
whipped cream
believe it or not the big cities a lot
kind of the little girls from the
country than it used to be especially if
they've got letters to the right people
oh it's easy enough for you to talk like
that you've been around but K is
different so was I one
I had hay in my hair too but it took out
fast after two seasons in the quarry
and no casualties either stop being a
rover boy I guess they do sound like
that but every time I think of her
having dinner with that guy could kick
the ceiling off oh that's the way it is
huh I guess I'm silly but I've never
been in love before
no I don't know whether I like it or not
well is it thanks
[Applause]
hello Barry its Kay
mr. Manning was crawled away suddenly
and I'm stuck with a chick it's $21 $21
what did you have Platinum pheasant
stuff with pearl Oh Barry please be
serious do you think you could raise it
yes I guess so
I may have to touch the landlady what do
I tell her all right honey you sit tight
I'll be right over
Oh mrs. mags
yes mr. Page can you let me have $20
I cannot mr. page well it's for cash
he's been in an accident I'm very sorry
mr. page I trust it won't be fatal
that's an ad of Eric Hayes in a jam she
needs 20 bucks is she in jail no in the
Park Plaza she's stuck with a check I
thought you went out with Mannering the
great picture stop she did how much
money do girls got well of all the nerve
see what bargains go it won't be money I
can tell you that much Berger open up
the penny Bank Snow White's in trouble
again
good evening miss Martin well fancy
meeting you here
did you get it oh yes I finally got it I
had to take up a collection to do it
though won't you join me in a cup of tea
I understand it's only $10 a pot at this
place Oh Barry please get me out I've
been sitting here for hours
waiter yes sir right away sir 5 10 15 20
21 they want I deeply regret this
inconvenience sir of course miss Martin
will never dine here again you know that
don't you I never said I was in hopes
never under any circumstances come dear
oh it was like a nightmare sitting in
there well look what he supposed
happened to his royal nibs I'd rather
not talk about it there thanks very it
was sweet of you to arrest me I'll pay
you back in the morning
where will you get the money in the
morning I have a little in the bank
No so the lady has money in the bank the
lady has money in the bank okay
he said the lady has money in the bank
Billie
you have money in the bank shall we that
very how do people say people are there
any other people in the world beside us
just a minute I have some unfinished
business come on in here is the office
who pick up these weapon coming well I
thought you liked to run oh you idiot
okay darling I love you we don't need
any money we don't need thing we will
need anything set the world for our
shooting game will you marry me if you
really want me to we may not be able to
eat a twenty dollar chicken dinner at
the Plaza but a hotdog in Central Park
is a lot more fun
come on and talk to me Charlie I can't
sleep I never sleep I can't even close
my eyes I know I haven't been able to
work that out yet oh there's a lot you
haven't been able to work out yet such
as for instance well Kate and Barry yes
she's in love with him charlie why
tonight when she couldn't pay her a
check he was the one she thought of well
it could have been you if you weren't so
tongue-tied oh I know but I never can
think of the right words I could you
should let me tell her I'm sick and
tired of you saying everything that I
want to
where is number 217 over there why my
water load Oh Oh be careful my fella huh
[Applause]
are you making noises just me by any
chance yeah what are you gonna do about
it
ye gods a talking horse hey you're
making too much noise down there you're
waking up the whole neighborhood will
you keep quiet yeah would you get along
mr. ventriloquist I beg your pardon I'm
looking for Miss k1k Martin I believe
she lives in this house wait a minute
I'll be right down yeah we'll be right
out
[Applause]
don't look now Burgin but I think I
picked up the Splinter what you want
strange time to be making a call but I'm
not making you call I wouldn't come at
this hour if it wasn't important and you
better wait until later no I want to see
you now
all right if you come up to my room I'll
see if I can get miss Martin for you
what a funny little fellow
you're quite in you is the young man you
know that shall I take a boat hand ha ha
ha
certainly not the gentleman is paying
you a compliment uh tell me how did you
work well he doesn't I do it all that's
why neither of us what's he laughing at
how did you get so cooked I beg your
pardon
don't wait to talk to a stranger oh well
let me put it another way it isn't doing
better than your question where plane
did you get this smooth he's that cute
I'm going down easy charlie
I'll clear things or help me that is
sounds like bourbon I hope it's not the
termites wiggling it charlie oh the love
of Pete what's going on here oh this
gentleman wants us decayed gentlemen
where's any gentlemen allow me to
introduce myself
ladies my name is Manny John Mary it's
him all right and is he Boyle
sorry if I've disturbed you lady Kate
Kate it's Edgar John Mann Rings
downstairs me wants to see you what did
you say John Mann rings downstairs he
wants to see you John Madden are you
sure positive
Oh mr. maverick I have in my album but
would you want to ask my wall
hello Catherine dear I do this telling
Edgar may I use your room for a moment
certainly Oh Mary you know Kevin this is
a great talent I thought that I'd seen
everything in my life this is still
extraordinary may I speak to you alone
would you excuse us please
[Applause]
I owe you an apology you're disappointed
in me aren't you
I don't know what to think would you
like a cup of coffee
no I'll be all right I shouldn't have
come here like this tonight but I wanted
to explain Lydia sighs at the Plaza
better seen it's all over Catherine over
because of me yes and you didn't tell
her even then I couldn't but why she
wouldn't let me she wouldn't even listen
to me now that is children I don't care
Oh someday you're going to hate me for
this you wish I'd never come don't you
say that
[Music]
well that's a sign of prosperity more
handkerchiefs and mirrors face I mean
good morning ladies hi bye
we can have that booking in here Oh
swell is stay here no I'll say she isn't
where is she
care to go up oh so she had to go up Oh
out where I don't know she didn't tell
me say what's going on here oh don't
mind us old boy we didn't get much sleep
last night
the traffic was terrific come on come on
Cora what's on your mind my boy nothing
honey
what's he talking about Mannering
dropped in to see Kay Mannering when at
4:00 a.m. as the crow flies it was a
little tight plastered any probably just
wanted to apologize to Kay for leaving
her at the Park Plaza at least that's
what we think course we couldn't hear
much after they closed the door Kate
took him home oh she did but the only
thing she could do Barry so this is the
way that idle rich live huh Charlie you
see bring it if you owe me a dramatic
actor we could have all this junk
I mean powder out Oh Charlie I work very
hard for all
come come all you do is mother little
and I have a popular leading lady I drew
some more coffee please
mr. burgundy mr. micawber yes yes just
put a hit on us awesome huh
putting on a little weight aren't you
Andrew oh excuse me ma'am no no no
that's quite all right old fellow I do
it myself sometimes
oh no sense of humor doll you know
Beggan is an outrage that the public
doesn't know charlie
he ought to be working constantly that's
what I say well we haven't worked for
months I'm afraid ventriloquism is a
thing of the past
all right don't be Andrews good mister
coming to the land spell of a telephone
very good
make it snappy Andrews with you what are
you going to do I'm gonna try to get
Charlie to Chauncey today did you hear
that Burgin I don't want you to try to
horn in on this thing either mr.
Cummings mr. Andrews let me talk with me
hello Tony this is John Mannering
talking hey Tony yeah what is our next
gamble Sunday week oh well that's
splendid
I've got a specialty act that I want you
to put in the name is Edgar Bergen and
Charlie McCarthy ha ha ha that's all I'm
gonna tell you I let them talk for
themselves when can you see them Lola
how long will you be there all right
I'll send them over
thanks very much Tony goodbye right away
oh it is already oh that's what you
think mr. Mannering I can't begin to
express well I mean after all you're a
stranger I mean well I hope that why
don't you let Charlie say it yeah what
are you trying to say is thanks and they
called me a dummy I wonder if I could
have some paper to wrap Charlie and
Andrew so favorably what's the idea
renting me up what are you Shane to me
all the planes come after another I
can't go out and bought daylight in the
pool dress to push around
I think we'd better wrap him up on the
floor and the floor in the air like no
that's nice thank you I'm sorry
easy easy Andrews you're gonna bust
something now if you bend your head
oh no you don't legging it will you take
his hat yes let give me a check on it
it's a Kip joint I do move down here
yeah
give me a pillow Berger I'm sorry I
[ __ ] a better up again good idea
let me die yeah I'll take it with me
what is burning judge refuses alimony or
last night eating my leg just use the
Clippers and back yeah I don't know how
to wrap your mouth suppose you get down
here an hour at you up I'll have him
tied up in a minute son you're terribly
sweet to do this I appreciate it
am i forgiven for what last night of
course
[Applause]
hey you're thinking me like oh I like
angry you out well I better run along
before the real language starts you'll
have there anything yet goodbye oh
thanks goodbye Kate
au revoir mr. mattering I'll give you a
ring tonight if I can get away from
Bergen thank you goodbye goodbye whom I
think about it Andrews Oh Andrew remind
me next time I come you think solving
hard life
why are we waiting while waiting for the
elevator would you please shut up
I suppose I can't you I know I'm variant
will you get down there all right down
down yeah yeah down and I'll be your
buddy I got a weak heart
[Music]
which is Mary's apartment right across
the hall
[Applause]
yes uh I want to see mr. man how you
expected no mr. mattering sees no one
except by appointment I'm sorry so you
tell them it's very important I've got
to see him right away
hi big nopon's huh if you will be good
enough to sit down sir I'll see what I
can do I beg your pardon sir there's a
gentleman who insists on seeing you are
you fighting in here of course what's
his name I didn't quite get it Sir
Andrew did you let in another process
ever I'll have your hide good morning
mr. Mallory yes what can I do for you
where is she she who mr. John mannery
the great movie actor huh
the guy that's so marvelous that all the
women fall in love with so easily well
I'm glad that I finally got a good look
at you what is this all my life I've had
an insane deserter oh oh oh you poor
dumb Oh
Barry how could you show your no
disruption I'll have you in jail for
this get out of my apartment
Oh Oh Barry what have you done boy Leo
peacocks face for my hope
oh you're stupid boom so that's how it
is
he's a poor darling and I'm a stupid
fool Barry all right
oh no oh oh I'm so sorry
let me oh no no no don't touch it what
does it hurt alright I shall consider
myself very fortunate if I'm not
disfigured for life we must have been
out of his mind tell me who was that
gangster he's not a gangster
he's very Paige the boy I told you about
last night we're going to be married
married yeah well things are happening
yesterday I discovered I was a father
today I'm to be a father in law and in a
year all things being equal father your
grandfather if you'll excuse me I'll try
to catch Barry and explain explain what
that you're my father I couldn't let him
go on thinking what he does about me
could I yes I'll be back in a little
while
[Applause]
I'm finished Andrews it's all over I
couldn't stop her she's going to tell
tell watch you'll know soon enough
read the morning papers read winch will
reach go ski and see how they laugh at
me but what have you done sir I don't
understand don't you know that it's a
crime to stay young how old am i Andrews
how do I look
not a day over 35 sir liar I'm 52 when
tomorrow every housewife and a medic is
going to read it over a morning coffee
get me a cup and make it strong yes sir
oh honey hi Barry why are you going out
to the corner for a cup of coffee come
on I'll go with him anything wrong there
no nothing you think we can still get
that booking maybe if we can make
Pittsburgh by tomorrow we can make it
you pack and I'll run down to pick up
the tickets and sign the contrary why in
the world don't ask a lot of questions I
just want to get out of this town as
quickly as possible I haven't killed
anyone happy what's the matter don't you
want to go killer if you want him
anything you want is okay with me it's
always been like that has me okay was
right she said you what I was what she
said you were in love with me what if I
were suppose I told you that but I felt
the same way about you I'd say you're a
liar all right so I'm a liar would you
marry me Barry have you forgotten that
last night you told me you were in love
with Kay that was last night I realize
now what a class ASAT I've been looking
for something real when I had it all the
time maybe I needed a good swift kick to
find it out Barry do you really mean it
what do you want me to do stand on my
head honey from now on it's you and me
remember that nobody else get you coffee
where are you going I'm gonna get us
booked before you change your mind
come in honey have you seen Barry yes I
just left him I've got to see him where
is he
gotta free an agent about a job we're
going on the road now I'm tacking now
for both of them just like all the time
so we did it okay do me a favor William
drag that suitcase out from under the
bed
okay okay what do you think he asked me
to marry him after think they got a five
years suddenly he asked me just like
that you could have knocked me over when
did this happen
just now what if I Cora did with that
clean laundry come on tell me I was
pretty scared when you came along I
thought he was nuts about you funny how
things turn out one minute you want to
take poison in the next just singing
like a canary oh you must think I'm
crazy carrying on like this but I think
it's swell when two people are married
and work together I'd give my life to
put Barry up where he belongs
I think God dream I pray for a success
it's all I care about now of course with
you is something else again you've got
your own career not to mention an NRI
you don't have to explain honey I wish
you all the happiness in the world both
of you
[Music]
[Music]
shall we go inside big - I want you to
meet mr. mr. Tucker
she's my protege miss Kavanagh simply
everybody in New York is here everybody
wants to see what she looks like
you'll still pick him I wish you all the
luck in the world
thank you and he means it too dude I do
excuse me a moment please
I thought you deserted this not me
flora you're looking lovelier than ever
thank you
what's going on in there Darla McCarty
is causing a riot among the guests stay
fine thing not allowing women at the
Lambs gamble I'd have given anything to
have seen Charlie mome down listen I'm
going to tell you a secret Rudy Vallee
was there and he was so impressed with
Megan that he's invited him to appear as
guest artists on his radio program good
heavens what a dummy gun to do on the
air never you mind I've complete faith
in Charlie
I don't think that funny
people people people I've never seen so
many faces such a distinguished looking
mob we're mingling with the cream of
society today that cream yes indeed
why do you mean well you know the cream
floats on top oh yeah
so the scum
of course isn't this something
not much like they were boarding house
before the clip street is it I miss 45th
Street if I weren't so busy you're lucky
to be away from it it's like a morgue
since you and honey and burying it like
burden will be checking out next heard
from honey lately head letter yesterday
they've been held over in Buffalo Oh had
they been married yet
no honey wants to wait until they play
her hometown she saw them she tell me
some more I want to be your friend
mm-hmm well you could be my friend if
you'd do me a little favor
oh I'd love to what was it would you
loan me 50 cents until Wednesday no no I
couldn't do that Tuesday till Monday
know what's going on here you don't need
to tell me that you're trying to borrow
money from this lady well I I didn't
mean to tell you no no no it wasn't that
I didn't get it
idea well I'm glad you didn't give it to
him and that reminds me young man
I left a quarter on my dresser this
morning yeah yes and when I came back
the quarter was gone it was yes and we
are the only two people up there well
there's always that is mr. Berg he
realize what you said yes I do your I
would you Doug I do well it's the last
straw the man has called me a common
thief now listen John if I'd made a
mistake oh there's nothing you can do I
want to apologize there's nothing you
can do mr. Lurgan
the wrong is done now listen do all you
do don't listen Charlotte I'd be glad to
apologize
there's nothing you can do alright I'm
sorry I want to apologize you know yes I
really don't think you took it don't you
think I took it I don't think so
uh-huh and I want to apologize you know
yes would you forgive me well you won't
mention it again I'll never mention it
again all right I'll forgive you thank
you yes now that it's all settled is it
all right for me to keep the quarter I
don't think that's very funny you don't
know well then why did you make me say
it's all I see you're not so clever
either mr. Berg no I'm not no I can see
your lips move oh you're that learns
about the universe
I'll hear about this when I get home
well I'm sorry about that will you watch
it please I will watch it yes yes it's
all as the illusion yes after all
there's no use of us both being dummies
no laughing at me yeah the great mr.
Bergen ha ha ha eventually question why
you went out with the bustle Oh
I can do that stuff myself what are you
doing down there George
go ahead pop it y'all right on well
where would you be without me yeah well
where would you be without me yeah well
you got me there
yeah well I'll show you where I would be
you'd be selling TVs oh no I wouldn't
sit right over there
oh that's how I kick me in the things
off more - more more - more come right
up here wouldn't you like to meet these
people who there's a very charming girl
- isn't he funny disgusting Mortimer
yeah what is your last name well I think
what is your last name
Oh me yes you more little more lean or
yes that's your first name yeah little
more all right the last name more and
more more a little more yeah well that's
the first thing well come on don't you
know your last name well I'm working on
it
come on no Laura no more no more no more
Snerd martyr martyr that's me all right
yeah well are you a city boy on the
country boy a country boy you work on a
farm you know or do you raise all corn
potatoes and stuff like that Island well
then you must have rich soil hmm I say
you must have rich soil where I'm the
farm
yes all right well if you raise all
those products yeah yes yes what oh no
you must have great fun haven't you yeah
rich boy yes on the farm on the farm
no you mean you mean it oh yeah yeah oh
yeah minor minor for oh I don't think
it's funny
are you hurt no try no more than water
just call me Dugan
I'm not a farmer but I'm a student of
palmistry oh yeah yeah you know I can
look into your hand here and I can read
your past in your future there's
absolutely now you have a very
interesting hand yeah yeah you'll notice
that your fingers and are all the same
shape you know five of a coin yeah
that's and now your index finger you'll
notice the nail on your index finger is
very broad well there's a lesson there
yes all the other sticker doing it again
now this is your heart line yeah yeah
that's the muddler yes you were in love
last summer weren't you
you mean to it yeah were you in love
with Tilly well now I'm very happy to
tell you more two more yeah that you're
going to inherit $2,000 oh boy yes but
through legal proceedings you're going
to lose it oh boy oh yeah I went through
that in a hurry I did not yeah are you
making much money well I make two
dollars alone selling fertile dirt you
do I used to only get a dollar load a
dollar load yeah are you making good
money now you know two dollars a load
for fertile dirt yeah great man who's
built yeah
increase to product 100% you know it's
the same old stuff
well wasn't that funny charlie come on I
wasn't that funny don't talk to me don't
touch me don't touch me all right did
you enjoy more two more Mike and lock
that's the most humiliating thing you've
ever done to me they're good what what
do you mean yeah
either he goes or I go oh I see great
room for three it was the Bergen that's
all that's all that's all now let's
judge it don't touch me all titles not
gonna go to level all right
I'll clip your song help me out
oh yeah yeah oh you're not mad at me yes
I am no you're not yes I am no you're
not oh yes I am that's a lovely suit you
have on oh you like it yeah I have a new
tailor yeah and I'm mad at you're not no
no charlie
I want you to look at no I don't want to
look at you know I can't stand listen
how are you you look at me look at me
you sure you mad at me huh are you mad
at me
well I did it it was a dirty trick I
know but are you mad at me
well I did I guess
blood is thicker than water how you
come smile my dear their heads better
you know I'm doing all this just to make
you happy I'd be terribly disappointed
if I thought I'd failed you haven't
[Music]
[Music]
darling I love you I came all this way
hoping you'd ask me to marry you
I couldn't but why not there's nothing
to prevent it now how can you say that a
blind man who has to be led round to the
hand I want to hold you by the hand
forever it's impossible
wherever we go there'd be glances
whispers I wouldn't mind for myself but
for you I couldn't have you pitied
because of me I love you too much then
there's nothing else in the whole world
I care about
it's no use Mary you're in the world I'm
out of it don't say that
good good she's fine nice quality thank
you I know your things Oh John I can't
tell you what a kick I got when I heard
your voice I'd give anything to see you
do it why Lou I haven't done a play in
12 years you know that I couldn't even
remember the lion I'd risk it however
suppose it's useless to argue
Hollywood's got this lovely regret
saying I'm not doing anything more this
year prep next season you're still
available
oh you don't mean to say you're not
gonna do this play I've got to have a
star in the man's part John if you won't
do it I can't think of anyone else
couldn't you persuade him oh no I
couldn't
well too bad from I am for you too well
goodbye miss Martin was very nice and
I'm sure you have no trouble on Broadway
thank you very much
John why don't you stick around a while
I might recall some of your family's
ancient glories remember when your
mother and father did romeo giulia
together for 39 weeks your brother did a
fellow for 40 seems a pity to think
you're not gonna carry on you dog well
if you change your mind oh it's too bad
you know you two would be very good
together but - Monica manners hi Joe
would you like to do this play with me
captain oh I'd love to but you must not
if you think it's wrong wrong how can it
be wrong it's the least I can do for you
if you're going on the stage at all it
ought to be here you with me you see up
there second row in the balcony the end
seat that's what I sat when I was 10
years old saw my mother for the last
time there was a long time alone too
long oh but how would I remember that
audience and their jewels and their
airmen standing there cheering and they
will again soon for you my dear and when
you've taken curtain call after curtain
call and they still want more of you
I'll come out and put my arm around you
before the footlights and I'll tell them
Catherine I'll tell them who you are
[Music]
I hear sold out for weeks Lou but it's
not ringing Mannering bed I hope you say
so new reviews how to go sensational I
mean as an actress that's what I mean I
thought she was Mannering in discovery
good evening miss Martin why haven't you
look lovely thank you excited I cannot
enjoy Oh Johnny you better call a fire
I'll probably buy both glasses cocktail
glasses cards and well have the table
about 4 foot down stage hello Katherine
hello Jill take a look at that house so
that uh uh when shall I put these out in
the hall is that the quarry rehearse
with yes Andrew yes sir
how's miss Mannering is he here yet no
miss what I've been here subscribe 30
you know how he dreads a New York old
knees always the last one in well even
so half hours been called you better go
check on 30 diction
[Music]
heyyo heyyo
come here
I think we've had the pleasure of eating
before I wouldn't call it a pleasure
we're seeing the show do you think I'm a
sucker still a blundering hot-headed
fool aren't you for my father I'd be
very happy if I never had to see you
again
I think I'll be able to arrange that all
right oh it isn't as easy as all that
you're still in love with her
otherwise you wouldn't be here go on in
maybe you learn something from you Oh
don't argue do as I say when you hear my
curtain speech come back and offer your
apology on stage places please
on stage ladies please your latest man
none sighs you've got loads of time and
loads of time my keen Andrew my love my
shuffle
are you alright sir well of course I'm
alright
can I get you some coffee no I don't
need any coffee I only had a couple of
eyeballs just to steady my nerves
important night Andrews house is sold
out yes sir
miss Martin in her dressing room yes sir
[Applause]
Andrews that's my first line I waited
for you in the god oh oh yes of course I
waited for you and we got you know
Andrew it's the strangest thing but I
can never remember my first lines on
opening night until I get on the stage
and then it all comes back to me mr.
Manley Oh Android you having too much
time Andrew is not your treat me like a
child they had to run six minutes before
I make my entrance and in six minutes I
can make up for dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde
[Applause]
[Music]
I wonder if Gary's here he said he
wasn't coming no that was for Holly's
benefit he isn't fooling her either
no I have Charlie's auto bed this is
forgery you know Charlie may sue me
thank you thank you mrs. Bergen
oh I'm not mrs. Bergen I'm mrs. McCarthy
[Music]
the scene is the drawing room where
Richard storms Long Island estate an
evening in late spring
[Applause]
[Applause]
see her that is yes
Muraki me not just now Miss Martin mr.
Mannering is dressing I just wanted to
thank you for the flowers and tell him
I'm going to do my best
thanks my dear good luck same to you
bottle snatcher I did it too ghastly I
never even suspected anything until he
brought her here
what hole here shop the house is full of
people nearly three she liked not thanks
job I need it you don't know what
tonight means to me
and when they're cheering you I cannot
and put my arm around you and I'll tell
them who you are
what did you say nothing Joe wait and
see I don't see why you made any help
direct this one oh I'm going oh the idea
of you dragging me here away from my own
game simply because you can get here
miss Plata mrs. catechol my aunt how do
you do
richard has told me a great deal about
you so I just told me a great deal about
you forgive me for leaving you now I'm
just waiting I'd like to have a cup of
tea with you if you're still here
tomorrow I should love that thing
goodbye Jenny goodbye Charlotte sorry I
can't help or almost kiss us goodbye
where is everybody except up Richard -
miss Rita I'd like to have a talk with
you I'm going to get anything I wish you
would
you're staying here mr. Manning on stage
just a moment I can't do it Andrews I
can't do it ten years of those twisted
pictures have done something to me it
isn't like carrying a plain New York but
they're ready to tell about anybody who
has the temerity to come back from
Hollywood which you were excellent in
Cleveland sir mr. Madeline please hurry
he read that first line again Andrew I
waited for you in the goddess I've got
it I waited for you when they garden I
hated to leave because I wanted to see
your face in the moonlight
what's next a little late it's quiet and
we can feel the home Richard it's
important that his family look after his
interests when he chooses to ignore me
I'm sorry you don't like me this door
because I'm leaving here tonight I'm
never coming back and Richard is coming
with me all your life you're much too
young for Richard you're not suited to
eat her that may be but he loves me and
I love him and there's nothing you can
do or say if it can change that don't be
too sure
[Applause]
he fools the confusing
I waited for you in the garden I hate
her to leave because I wanted to see
your face in the moonlight Richard can't
be going away from here where it's quiet
and we can be alone
we can be alone here please Richard I'm
not comfortable here my next line
Larry this is my home Mary this is my
home I want you to love it as I do
soon it will be all yours we've a lot to
talk over before that please Richard
let's go whatever you say my dear I'll
get my things and meet you in the car
good matter with him Andres just nervous
that's all
you were very nice miss Thank You
hundred Richard I didn't know you were
down the others have all going to suffer
happy what's happening did you bring sir
oh yes sir
bring me my haven't cold please and have
my car whizzing yes sir good they're not
going out in with us evening huh huh oh
yes yes I'm going into town have you
forgot me okay
[Music]
he is drunk
make my apologies doctor go in the
morning that's my next line
[Music]
and I went to town all right guys I even
go into town without consulting you
will you stop interfering in my life go
on - he's code
your coat sir we do believe and I think
got a Daenerys after speech Richard
Richard you can't go on like this I sit
as long as I intend to this girl's
presence in this place is it it's an
intolerable humiliation
[Music]
[Music]
and you cannot help
never seem to enjoy yourself as much
solid as well you're making this way
never seem to enjoy yourself
[Music]
[Music]
what's happened ladies and gentlemen due
to the sudden illness of mr. Mannering I
regret to announce we were unable to
continue the performance this evening
your money will be refunded at the box
office
[Music]
[Applause]
well
why don't you say it Catherine why don't
you say that I failed you why don't you
say that I'm a drunken has-been
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'd stay here for the word if I we use
that I would trying to go out
[Applause]
with that memory I didn't see his face
it looked like him
[Applause]
[Applause]
well you gotta breath to congratulate me
why don't you think of my night of crime
[Music]
I can't imagine what happened
Drakken so far sound right when I talk
he smashes on wood it being funny the
Front's of tactic
yeah certainly was Mannering
I saw him myself he was hit by taxi I
tell him badly injured it's K marking
with him will stick there call me if
anything happens
hey Suzy find out where K Martin lives
get her on the phone how should I know
[Applause]
we put this stuff in the dressing room
how anybody leave it there quiet please
hello reporters miss Martin has nothing
to say she won't talk to any reporters
it's nearly 11:00 Edgar I know I've got
to beat it I'm on the air and a half
hour
good luck Edgar thanks a lot for
everything okay if I could only tell you
how sorry all right Lancelot you've said
your piece get going you know what
Charlie will do if you're late what
he'll clip your Bergen he'll move you
down we'll do what we can it's useless
to operate opiates to relieve his pain
at about all we can do for the present
have you notified his family mr. banner
he has no family keeps calling for
someone named Katherine oh yes do you
think he might see her sir well there's
no reason why mr. Mannering shouldn't do
anything he wants to know thank you sir
well doctor you know the other thing
[Applause]
listen operator I told you Miss Martin
isn't talking to anybody no not anybody
she has no statement to make
yes oh let them say anything they like
everything that's nasty and mean has
already been printed in all those gossip
columns how can they do me now oh you
mustn't feel like that cave oh it's time
for Edgar do you mind of course not
he'd never forgive us if we didn't
listen in tell him how bad is
and now ladies and gentlemen the boys
who have New York at their feet Edgar
Bergen Adam Jolly Messiah mr. Bergen the
fall we continue with another broadcast
I want you to answer me one question
do I get an increase in my loans after
all 75 cents a week isn't good enough
what's that they went up clean today
very funny tonight mr. beragon
I'm afraid not charlie ladies and
gentlemen will you forgive us for not
being at our best this evening because a
dear friend of ours a great actor met
with the disaster he opened in a new
play tonight his first appearance on
Broadway in 12 years because he was
nervous he went up in his lines and for
the first time in a long and brilliant
career the curtain had to be rung down
on John Mannering must have been a
terrible blow to his pride if only we
could tell him that it didn't matter
that every man is entitled to one more
but we can't of course 20 minutes after
the curtain came down John Mannering was
struck by a taxi and is now lying close
to death Cara if any of his friends are
listening and they ought to go to him
he's at the Midtown hospital Midtown
hospital where's the head you cold I'll
thank you
[Applause]
Andrews he's going to be alright isn't
he the reports are exaggerating
I'm afraid not miss he wants to see you
it will make him very happy to know
you're here
I'll wait for you here
[Applause]
No
that goes
the reporters
[Applause]
something I
wanna tell them I've done a flower girl
mr. Manor you were asking for Miss
Martin yes endless be sure be sure to
tell her if you see her much I love her
[Applause]
I'm here
[Applause]
with Catherine
[Applause]
to think I could be so selfish and cruel
darling
you've made me happier and all the
people I've ever known put together my
son right here
I said cry
[Applause]
I didn't keep my promise yes I didn't
tell them about you
it doesn't matter but I'm going to add
rose yeah reporters the downstairs if
you want them to come up now yes yes
[Applause]
hurry you must be quiet I'll rest
darling try to forgive me for being such
a bad father
what darling you have never done
anything for you that a father should
wait to tell the world about you but at
least I can do that Oh doctor
[Applause]
miss Ryan gentlemen mr. man ring has
just passed away
[Applause]
it goes to the Pennsylvania station
[Applause]
Kevin I'm very sorry you're going away
why don't you stay here and do another
play for me right away I can't not well
I'm I'm still a Roman holiday for all
the gossip comes I feel like were
capitalizing on his death but he would
have wanted you to go on well maybe next
year when they'd forgotten all about me
I'll come back and try again well
whenever you do decide let me know
thanks you've been very kind you wanna
make that train you better hurry okay I
think I have everything shall I take
this please will mr. bokun hello Andrew
do what stammers excuse me good hello
miss Cora miss Martin I was so afraid
I'd missed you you know I wouldn't go
without seeing you and going through mr.
Manning's effect I came across this
letter of yours I thought perhaps you'd
like to keep it my letter of
introduction Thank You Andrews you you
won't not if you don't want me to miss
but don't you think it might be better
for you know a nerd no one would
understand my waiting until now to
announce it if he had told it would have
been different but if I were to tell now
it would only cause a lot more
unpleasant publicity about him I don't
want that I understand hello thank you
are you going home okay doll yes Barry I
know I always have and I always will
I was a fool jealous and suspicious I
tried to forget you I nearly wrecked
honey's life it doesn't seem possible so
many things could happen in so short a
time and all because of this letter the
letter that was to open the doors of
fame success and happiness and now now
he's dead did he mean so much to him
more than anyone would ever know
and I guess there's nothing else to say
very dear will you please read this
please
[Applause]
tell him to hurry we'll never get to the
station in time yes step on it oh let's
not bother they'll never go there you're
pretty sure aren't you
listen Cora that boy and that girl
clicked the first moment they looked at
each other it's that kind of a look that
lasts until eternity
my my how poetic oh shut up l Stella
Edgar's Charlie old was going to come
between us
how do you like that this is my car
Bergen bought it for me so I wouldn't
have to be wrapped up the newspapers
every time I went out oh I'm sorry
Charlie but you are in the way yeah mr.
Bergen and I have things to discuss
oh sure I suppose you wanna sit on his
lap huh Charlie huh would you be good
enough to no I wouldn't all right don't
be a step as long as our between you
you're safe why if I leave she'll take
you like grant took Richmond join hands
and chorus we will take our time the
hotel tonight
ba-baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]